whole point is that like it's all down
to choices and the man made a choice too
because I can't get pregnant unless he
nuts it I I understand that but I'm
sorry then there's nothing arguing
you're the one that's only you're in
control of who gets born abortion's
legal okay well as soon as as soon as he
nuts completely out of his control
listen and I'll just say something
though that was Advocate that I had a I
had my child and we in the dead went
together and I didn't take a penny from
him and the government wanted me to but
I decided that no it was better off that
my child I look after him myself
anything he wants to give his son if he
wanted to is extra but I worked hard and
I've done it all on my own because it
was this list because it's this headache